and a good friday afternoon to you thank
you so much for joining us here at four
i'm kirsten joyce and i'm christian cass
that is new at four the weather across
the country is affecting
how much vaccine we receive right here
in nevada the white house announcing six
million doses are delayed the good news
here at home
is more than half a million vaccines
have been administered our i-team found
nevada still ranks near
the bottom in terms of other states in
the number of doses administered
per capita and that's likely due to the
amount we're getting
our goal here and what we have to really
focus on here in nevada
is to be able to use what we receive
and so i feel like we've made some
wonderful gains and been able to scale
up operations
very much to the credit of our
vaccinators who are on the ground
the issue may be due to nevada's growing
population
our state covid task force believes the
white house
is using 2018 census data to allocate
vaccines
since then more than 100 thousand people
have moved here